hello everybody I'm Peter Brown for
gamespot with Randolph Ramsay and we're
here to talk to you about battle born
which you can probably see in front of
you on the video player this is a hero
shooter Peter what is a hero shooter by
the way let's be honest this is a MOBA
in shooters outfit well it sorta is ok
we have covered this game in the past
and there was a lot of sort of mobile
like elements in the multiplayer what
we're looking at specifically here is
coop the coop story mode and we played
basically the one level a few times over
experimented with a few different
characters and this is what they're
gonna be showing at e3 this year yeah
and you talk about characters there are
a lot of them and they are all very
different from one another and the
premise of the story kind of justifies
that right every star in the universe
has gone dark there's one star left and
everyone from all the dark planets that
have survived are sort of you know
ascending on this one planet you know
fighting for it and also fighting to
defend it from an evildoer who is trying
to take it out blah blah blah it's
actually a really depressing story line
like the entire universe is being
snuffed down yeah essentially apart from
this one star and all these races have
come along to protect it and that and
that's the whole reason for having this
you know variety of you know different
types of characters different types of
styles they had 10 playable in the demo
that we played and we you know we played
a few different types but apparently for
the full release are looking at 25 they
sort of do a they sort of do a line
towards you know their typical akhtar
you know chew the type styles where you
know you do have one who is a tank you
know we have DPS characters that type of
thing you know the one the first one I
think we both played was the dwarf guy
Boulder yeah and I kind of defaulted to
him by accident because someone else
chose all the characters that I thought
was really cool but he didn't it being
pretty fun I mean I think every
character sort of has a nice range of
options when it comes to attacking they
have ranged attacks and melee attacks
and the dwarf is obviously a bit of a
tank he's a little slow but what I found
is as you level up it's new for every
match but you get to choose different
abilities and they're called
augmentations here and those opened him
up for me where I felt like I was being
much more effective as a range plate
player like a range tank versus a you
know
brawler yeah and you mentioned you know
the whole MOBA influence and this is
very much yeah I'm over influence in
this game in which you know you have
this sort of like skill tree that will
basically set you from exciting from the
start at the start of you know every
level so you go through i think what 10
levels i think and you can basically you
know depending on you know your
playstyle you can switch it up from from
stock from mission to Mission and you
know boulder hwy and i started off as
you know just being basically very sort
of like slow and all really had was a
shield and you could improve him quite a
bit country yeah you know he also
started off with a projectile where you
could throw i believe it was an axe but
as i leveled him up i got faster am i
cool down times got better and and in
terms of throwing that little axe i got
to the point where i could throw it and
if it didn't hit my target would return
to me and i could throw it again
instantly which was great because when i
first started and you'd miss you think
crap i have to wait another 10 15
seconds to use it again so you
definitely do feel the evolution of the
characters throughout just one match
which is good i'm very curious though
how they're going to play with all these
different character types and really you
know home each individual one to be that
great experience yeah i managed to play
a couple different characters there was
like foreign who was a an archer top
class and she was quite good obviously
you know a more of a range character had
a healing filled which could you know
help them help the fellow players and
the real weird one was a one was one
called or rendi which is sort of like i
know you can publish your own screen now
but she has four hands you know she'd
come cuz she cast spell she has this
really cool sort of spell where she'll
jump back and you know put this robe
bones in front of us so long anyone
who's trying to grab a gets damaged by
that and those guys felt you know
sufficiently different enough so you
know i think there's gonna be you know a
bit of variety at the at the end of the
day with this game yeah the the variety
has me a little bit concerned because it
doesn't feel like a cohesive cast or a
cohesive world but it's justified in the
story yeah but are you talking about the
design of the fame the design of the
characters yeah they'd see there they
look like they came from different
worlds and that makes a lot of sense but
it just it the identity of the game
feels a bit confused to me but i will
say i was happy to find a character that
i really like that i wish i could have
played so i guess I kind of understand
this the guy I'm talking about he's sort
of based off of the gundam mecha
characters
is you know he can fly a little bit and
he's got all this great stuff and I was
like I really want to play that guy so I
I get what they're going for just the
broader perspective I hope they can
figure out a way to make this world feel
more cohesive yeah this whole mix of
styles i think you know gearbox of
developers have sort of talked about in
the past which is you know they have you
know open themselves up in this said
okay what what are the sort of things
that we like what the sort of things
that influences our games and let's try
and i'll put it together so I get what
you're coming from with that sense where
there's a lot of things happening down
design point of view in this game well
what did you think of the actual
gameplay though I thought it was good
you know I enjoy playing it and the
co-operative experience was was good i
mean it's very much a raid like
experience at least the demo that we
played and in that sense I thought it
was not bad you know i mean i'm not
going to rush out and buy it right away
but that's also because i am not a big
gear box fan i don't know that i really
like their humor that much but that said
if you really do like games like
borderlands i feel like this is going to
really resonate with you i think this
one has a lot of promise for me I think
you know I'm interested to see you know
where the actual single-player sort of
co-op type stuff will will actually take
me because you know I'm not really that
interested in the like the multiplayer
stuff the stuff that they've shown
before but but this type of thing I can
see myself going through an entire
campaign will you know with a few people
you know trying out different characters
all the way through and there seems to
be a lot of variety there so I'm looking
forward to you know what that should
come out with
you